a family is asking for help tonight as
they search for a man who went missing
on mount charleston rock stanley who was
visiting the area from texas left her
hike early tuesday morning and never
came back sasha loftus spoke with his
loved ones tonight as they continue to
look for answers she joins us in studio
with more sasha denise rock's family
tells me these last few days have been
an absolute nightmare rock has a
military background and though he was
hiking alone he was prepared so they
would have never expected this to happen
described as a father teacher and marine
rock stanley's family says he's a man
that's impossible to forget any of us
are willing to do whatever we got to do
to get him home but those who love him
are now frantically searching for
answers three days after he vanished on
mount charleston i feel like at this
point you know every hour that goes by
it's
not good for him or us rock's son ken
stanley says the 75 year old and his
wife are here on a yearly trip from
texas
and he got up early tuesday morning to
hike the north loop trail
rock never returned potentially slip may
have gotten hurt might be sitting
somewhere right now so that's these are
all the
possibilities that we've gone through
our head since then rock's kids wife and
grandkids red rock search and rescue and
metro police have been working around
the clock to find him he got lost on the
trail and he was trying to backtrack to
let my mom know aside from that text and
one other call wednesday it's been radio
silence so they're asking everyone for
help he's been a father to many many
people he's affected in a very positive
way hundreds and hundreds of people so
rock can be reunited
with the people who miss him most he's
had a great life and we're just not
ready for it
now rock was last seen around 5 a.m on
tuesday again on the north loop trail on
mount charleston he is 5 foot 9 about
180 pounds and was wearing a yellow
jacket gray shorts and a blue backpack
if you have any information call the
number on your screen
eight two 702-828-2900 zero seven